Isaiah our new favorite Isaiah Factor
however you want to read the title the
one he's good he's covering today Vice
for starting an only fans page in the
New Year this guy is such a weird
degenerate I love him though he's so
weird he rules it's like if Carl Winslow
was a piece of [ __ ] yes yeah welcome
back to the factor on since it only fans
can be a nice little side game let's get
some of these hoes in here to talk to
him I am I subscribe to 16 7 of these
[ __ ]
a full career wait for what oh no no no
Frozen what what is this what am I about
to watch just wait for it keep playing
okay however before you get naked in
front of a camera shooting at coochie or
that's long what
what I told you
coochie you're that what what yeah man
my man is [ __ ] wild [ __ ] yeah buddy
yes
only thing make me wish my phone had
smell-o-vision
it's like a movie Dr Hibbert yeah
That Coochie or that's long keep in mind
that are you laughing because there's
somebody from Fox 26 Houston to suit
coochie man and this is Fox it just goes
to show you how degenerate Houston is
yeah
this is their Fox News affiliate this is
the conservative news station what
does that mean Tucker's allowed to say
coochie yeah he can do whatever he wants
bro did you not see you can watch his
ass
interviewing the CEO of Rumble the other
night and on who's interviewing him and
they played a segment of the interview
and they tried they forgot to censor the
guy saying [ __ ] oh yeah so I was like oh
cool so that's pretty cool
find a successful page takes serious
strategy that's where my next guests
come in Abby Rose and Sophia Sapphire
is he is he actually bringing them into
the studio is he bringing them in I knew
this was good that's why I said I want
to meet these hoes because he always
brings in somebody on the website well
what are those [ __ ] are icky and and
virgie's in love
yeah yeah she's very icky all right
right now right or left
all right
right right right
ah
all right so before you go too far the
one on the left has a drug problem
that's why she's thin so you one on the
right had a drug problem right
yeah that's why yeah she probably put it
behind her yeah
that's all
good this is both ends of a methadone
clinic
it's the people the people that get
there early and the people that get
there late exactly this is a uh this is
a this is a girl with a 30-day N8 chip
and a girl with a three-year NHS
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] the one of the left
snacks a cigarette and the one on the
right is the sleeve of Oreos
the one on the right is the one on the
left sponsor yes
the one on the right is the one on the
left dealer
the one on the right still smokes weed
you know the flame surprise she's weed
sober she's weed sober yeah yeah
what should you do on only fast your
first step when you show your [ __ ]
immediately show your [ __ ] right away
right away we want to see everything and
are you gonna show me your [ __ ] I'm
sorry your coochie
I'll show you my schlong yeah I say a
factor uncensored Fox 27.
you're starting your own website
I would say the first thing a lot of
creators is to shower shower and maybe
shave a lot of women will realize you do
get hair around your butthole and you
got to take care of that okay first get
in over their heads with because they
think they're going to be successful
right off the bat she has a pretty face
uh However unfortunately you do need
people to network too right Mark it too
guys who jerk off to you I guess I'll
Translate
always recommend girls actually starting
with camming if they don't have a
following I know a guy Andrew Tate he
gets you in the biz
so what is caming for us who are not so
you know you know
what is a camera
you [ __ ] a lot he's I can't liar
Isaiah
webcaming is a webcam web
oh oh
webcam I thought oh oh
webcam of course
so I'm wondering when you do the cam and
right and I got my computer and I'm
jacking off can you see me also or I
never knew where that worked I'm jacking
off my slung and I'm looking at your
coochie on a webcam are you watching me
or it's just the FBI
okay yes live streaming I'm sorry I'm
getting carried away now tell me more
about this what's it called
pornographic well I've never heard of it
man I'd love to ask questions to the
other girl but she's knocking off
in front of it's you know in front of
everybody so would that be like free
just a tease for free and then say you
see more and what would the link be and
what time are you on
what is your username and what's your
phone number
research never mind I'll just checking
our [ __ ] on our release forms like
Master Po did back in the day put it as
a strip club but you're in your bedroom
okay got it got
it yeah somehow I think a night wave
yeah yeah in your bedroom got it good
yeah so the one on the left is a little
bit on drugs yeah yeah yeah
or guys that don't necessarily the one
on the left was nervous to go on TV and
had an edible and it's like it's kicking
right now social media following to
start off with caming because right off
the bat you're going to be able to talk
about your only fans and spread the word
about it all and network yourself you're
spreading people in the community
whereas if you have no social media
following
um and you don't do camming it's just
kind of
you're it's going to be really hard
that's like masturbation
I love him I said I love Isaiah
is it Isaiah naked
is wait is is that the one on the left
this is both of them they're kissing
yeah yes oh they together hoes they're a
team
friendship good for them I'd watch it
I'd watch I mean I wouldn't pay for it
but I'd watch it
and what and what's masturbating other
than camming without a cam and an
audience and you're alone in your room
guys another reason you got other
revenge of assist.locals.com that's the
fun chat I promise you
[Laughter]
to be perfect in shape because no
obviously not really not even
because there are people with niches out
there right whoa hey hey yo I'm allowed
to say it oh sorry I apologize
oh absolutely you know they like it all
yeah it's that's what I like
and what's with defeat things person who
came here
are they gonna really just show them
kissing on Vox what's happening what's
happening
is calling them only fans people it
makes it sound weird just call them
adult content creators or something yeah
that's actually that's way better I
would agree with that awkwardly going oh
yeah you are only fans people like
saying it like it's a [ __ ] slur or
something all right now let's see a clip
all right now let's do it again one more
time
yeah people love that oh yes the more
weird the better yeah and and that's
what's cool about the community
not that I'm in defeat but let's say my
friend was in defeat do you do feet
that you learn now what are these
private shows can you take it directly
out of my checking account
I'm asking for newspaper what about
y'all take Litecoin
I'm pretty Diversified in Litecoin at
the moment I got a lot of Litecoin I got
a little heavy on the Litecoin bag learn
that sexuality is very fluid and
everybody has a thing and so
it's build confidence so at least for me
it did yeah they're playing a lot of
videos of them kissing
yeah I'm not complaining but it's weird
to see that on Fox affiliate right it's
it's Fox Houston uh Houston Atlanta
Vegas I was already a pretty confident
person but why
that's nice
[Music]
it's very mean literally no reason for
you to be really you don't have any
respect for this girl I have survived
none
and being in this industry has made me
way more confident of a person I would
say yeah yeah is the one on the left
gonna talk or is she just there to
[ __ ] figure [ __ ] the other one how
does this work
and so did you have any reservations
about getting a only thing from my
research the one on the left is the one
that has the the only fans and the one
on the right is the one that helps her
out with the owning fans so they both
have the same only fans yes yeah did you
have any reservations about getting on
only fans do you have anything do you
have any Fentanyl
I'm tired
funny story I accidentally this is
fennel and now if I don't do fennel
every 10 minutes I'm gonna die the last
time I ate was three days ago
and it was a Pop Tart I found on the
floor
boys are gonna hesitate about putting
herself out look either get a whole nose
ring piercing or get a nun but this tiny
one is weird right yeah it's a little
bit odd get a big one and by the way is
it me or is it in two in the front of
the nose shouldn't it be more centered I
mean she has a long witch nose but like
shouldn't it be more centered everyone
to see um nice this too shall pass
tattoo that's very original and it's
very original fonts too
oh God
that's a font that comes with Microsoft
Office yeah it's live laugh love uh it's
it's live laugh love Sans
that's a good point this too shall pass
is just it's just live laugh love for
addicts that font is called times new
basic
my background actually was
um I helped run a burlesque supper club
in Houston back
and clearly the thin one yes that's what
I mean she was the thing good looking
one is the burlesque Supper Club of the
burlesque show where they were like 80
of them eat your food
no no no whenever I hear supper
burlesque Supper Club is where they
bring you in and they feed you porridge
like you're a newsie
stupid
well putting herself out there for
everyone to see my background actually
was a [ __ ]
um I helped run a burlesque supper club
in Houston back in the day so being
around the art of teas is not foreign to
me
um but being involved in it it's just
fancy way it's a fancy way of saying to
the hole
no it's her her uncle her uncle used to
call her a tease all the time
[Laughter]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
on the management side and I'm on the
Performing side so to speak so yeah you
know her real last name is in Sapphire
right it's Sophia cubic zirconia
I mean you're gonna get something
but I mean for me it was just exploring
something for me that I wanted you
needed money we know we get it economy
hit us all yeah we're all in rough shape
friends I went in it with no
expectations at all like whatever
happens happens if I have one fan cool
if I have a million fans awesome no
you're not gonna keep putting things in
your [ __ ] and [ __ ] for one fan
really just that's called marriage
at that point hello at that point you
might as well
one minute to um try something different
and something new and it's you know been
a really cool experience now we hear you
guys work together can we get a little
preview just a little kissy kiss wait
oh wait what
no what is he doing no
why don't you give each other some sugar
for Isaiah what is he doing he's about
to take out his wallet he's about to
take out a schlong what is going well
this is the news
this is the best thing ever
Frozen I know you found this this and
then I want you to start playing with
yourself a little bit and then you just
stop playing with yourself a little bit
and then slowly start to sort of vibe
together all right all right now talk on
her hair okay now smell it a little bit
I said smell that bitch's hair
let's work together
what is this [ __ ] 1990s Howard Stern
I love this I want to be a fox reporter
I love this journey for Isaiah don't go
too far go here don't go too far or do
like I don't care honestly I'll edit
this [ __ ] out we need to go goodbye
we're not doing this I'm watching it on
TV
you heard the slop
slop slop good night
I'm seeing if he has a boner
is he married uh nope no wedding ring
there's no wedding
after he was if he was he's not after
that after that [ __ ] interview
that would be a I would expect to be a
little bit of trouble wow we played a
lot of Isaiah videos but this was my
fake [ __ ] favorite one dude
holy [ __ ] uh this is amazing could you
give you a little Smoochy come on baby
girl